[Musique]
c'est de la mise en scène tout le temps
le lendemain il va dire qu'elle boit du
sang quel snif du poppers
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
Miss USA qui a été élu Miss Univers le
15 janvier dernier la plus belle femme
voilà du monde lors des élections Miss
Universe univers et Miss Monde
[Applaudissements]
elle est jolie elle est très belle mais
ce qui est très amusante et qui fait le
tour des réseaux sociaux c'est qu'elles
doivent chacune arriver et crier leur
pays
sauf qu'il y en a une elle avait un mot
à dire c'était la dernière elle a chié
et depuis bah ça fait le tour et tout le
monde se moque d'elle c'est le pays qui
a annoncé regarder
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
elle s'appelle Madonna et bien son ami
Amy summer la met au défi c'est en train
de boire de l'alcool il s'éclate à 31 et
les met au défi de chanter tous ces
tubes et de refaire une tournée Madonna
paire du coup elle demande ce qu'elle va
faire une tournée
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
la confirme
mondiale baptisée de célébration tour
regardez les places vont jusqu'à 500
dollars est-ce que vous savez pourquoi
400 les assurances ont tellement peur
que comme pour Justin Bieber elle passe
trois dates et qu'après bourré machin
elle parce que sa dernière tournée elle
en a beaucoup annulé elle a annulé des
dates parfois les gens étaient dans la
salle elle est pas venue voilà le
concert en France je vais vous dire
qu'il a été soldes outré vidé en 5
minutes
c'est hallucinant elle passera par Paris
des 12 et 13 novembre elle va
interpréter ses plus grands hits et
voilà les places ça va jusqu'à 400 euros
je trouve ça où elle est incroyable
c'est que si l'histoire est vraie c'est
vraiment ça c'est un 31 c'est ce que
raconte un 31 tu joues un peu avec des
jeux pour boire tu es bourré c'est elles
ont joué action ou vérité et elle elle a
pris action et le mec lui dit action tu
perds tu fais une tournée mondiale elle
a perdu elle l'a fait c'est pas un génie
ça peut s'y croire ou pas
quand elle a commencé sa carrière nous a
dit qu'elle était arrivée avec un dollar
à New York mais c'est vrai évidemment
depuis quelques mois sur les réseaux
sociaux elle ne fait que ça c'est de la
mise en scène tout le temps elle met un
panier de basket si je le mets je suis
homosexuel le lendemain il va dire
qu'elle boit du sang quel snif du Popper
elle ne fait que ça son visage change
elle est plus ça va plus elle ressemble
à offrir Bogdanov où on sait pas trop et
juste finir Madonna elle est comme tous
les gens qui ont gagné tant d'argent
pendant tant d'années elle a besoin
d'argent il y a pas longtemps à gagner
entre 100 à 150 millions de dollars par
an aujourd'hui elle en gagne beaucoup
moins ça fait 15 ans qu'elle a pas fait
un tube donc cette tournée elle est
importante mais c'est vrai
[Musique]
que son mari l'a trompé est résumé
depuis le début Benoît à cause de la
confiture c'est à dire qu'elle partait
donc ils vivaient ensemble donc dans le
foyer familial quand elle rentrait de
ses tournées ou de ses prestations elle
rentre chez elle il y avait de la
confiture dont son mari n'aura folle pas
et ça diminué ça diminue du coup alors
après en vidéo en vidéo des mots sur son
ordinateur et se sont aperçus après par
la suite qui avait une jeune fille qui
passait de 25 ans donc de moins 20 ans
moins qu'elle et là elle s'est aperçu de
tout ça et comme quoi il l'a trompé la
confiture c'est vrai et c'est ce qui lui
a fait enclencher le lambeau
elle a eu des choses très claires mais
en fait la vérité c'est que Piqué a
rencontré une nana de 23 ans dans dans
une soirée il y a eu selon leurs proches
un vrai coup de foudre il y a eu
adultère pendant quelques mois et bosser
pour lui jusqu'à quel finissent par
découvrir le poteau rose ils se sont
séparés au début ça allait à peu près
puis ça a dégénéré depuis quelques temps
c'est la guerre on l'a vu faisant une
sorte de doigt d'honneur à destination
de son ex lors d'un match de baseball de
leur fils il y a une chanson voilà 50
millions de vues en moins de 24 heures
alors la réponse du piqué j'ai appliqué
a répondu à Shakira alors que c'est le
terrain lui reproché à être passé d'une
Ferrari une twingo en passant dès à sa
copine actuelle
il est arrivé avec une Renault
meilleur coup de pub de Renault pour
l'année pour Renault c'est gigantesque
cette histoire qui lui offre évidemment
la bagnole et comme elle a dit aussi tu
m'as acheté une Rolex contre une Casio
bah qu'est-ce qu'il a fait c'est ça je
vois
ça
[Musique]
va
encore plus loin parce que Shakira du
cas du coup elle elle place sur sa
terrasse une sorcière il faut que je
sache qu'elle habite en face de son ex
belle-mère la mère de piquer habite en
face
[Rires]
il faut savoir surtout
ce qu'il faut savoir surtout c'est
qu'ils sont extrêmement superstitieux et
que tout ce qui est sorcière etc pour
eux attire le mauvais œil et elle a fait
comme on dit chez moi je mette elle a
fait exprès elle a mis devant devant
elle et toute la journée elle écoute son
disque à fond pour que tout le monde
entendait que ça belle-mère l'endroit